IT ALLOCATES $3 BILLION TO
DEVELOP TREATMENT, $2 BILLION TO
THE CDC, $1 BILLION TO FIGHT THE
VIRUS OVERSEES.
THE CLIP YOU JUST SAW, VP
REFERENCE THE DIAMOND CONTEST
CRUISE SHIP, WHICH IS WHERE MY
NEXT GUEST CONTRACTED THE
CORONAVIRUS.
JOINING ME NOW IS CARL GOLDMAN,
A PASSENGER ON THAT SHIP, NOW
UNDER QUARANTINE AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF THE MEDICAL
CENTER.
CARL, HOW ARE YOU FEELING, MY
DEAR?
MY GOODNESS, SORRY ABOUT WHAT
YOU HAVE BEEN THROUGH.
HOW DO YOU FEEL?
>> THANKS, LAURA.
IT’S BEEN A BIT OF AN ORDEAL,
BUT I FEEL FINE.
THIS VIRUS FOR ME WAS PRETTY
LIGHT, EQUAL TO A VERY, VERY
MILD COLD.
AND TODAY, I’M FEELING FINE.
UNFORTUNATELY, I AM STILL
TESTING POSITIVE, AND SO I’M
GOING TO BE STUCK HERE FOR A
WHILE LONGER.
>> Laura: I HAVE A QUESTION.
HOW MANY TIMES DO YOU HAVE TO
TEST NEGATIVE IN ORDER TO BE
RELEASED FROM QUARANTINE?
>> WE HAVE TESTING DONE THREE
DAYS IN A ROW, AND THEY TEST
WITH A SWAP THAT GOES DEEP UP
INTO EACH NOSTRIL AND ONE DOWN
THE THROAT, SO THEY HAVE TO COME
UP NEGATIVE IN ALL THREE OF
THOSE, THREE DAYS IN A ROW.
THEY’VE GOTTEN REAL HIGH TECH
OUT HERE.
OMAHA IS ONE OF THE TOP CENTERS
IN THE COUNTRY, SET UP BY THE
CDC DURING THE ANTHRAX SCARE, SO
EVERYTHING IN BIO CONTAINMENT
AREA FOR ABOUT TEN DAYS, WHEN I
FIRST GOT HERE, WHICH WAS LIKE A
SCENE OUT OF A MOVIE.
AND WHERE I AM RIGHT NOW IS IN A
MUCH LOWER TECH AREA.
QUARANTINE.
WHAT’S FUNNY, I GET MY RESULTS
EVERYTHING HIGH-TECH, BUT HERE’S
MY RESULTS, COMING ON A POST-IT
NOTE.
>> Laura: OH, A POST-IT NOTE.
YOU COMPARE THE DISEASE, YOU
WERE IN PRETTY GOOD HEALTH WHEN
YOU CONTRACTED IT, CORRECT?
>> RIGHT, I COMPARE IT TO A MILD
COLD.
IF I WASN’T CONTAGIOUS, I WOULD
HAVE BEEN AT WORK THE NEXT DAY,
AFTER A 24-HOUR STRETCH.
I HAVE THE SAME SYMPTOMS MOST
PEOPLE TEND TO BE GETTING,
FEELING FINE, AND THEN, THE
NORMAL TEMPERATURE ZOOMS UP, AND
IN MY CASE, I WAS ALREADY ON THE
PLANE BACK TO AMERICA, SLEPT FOR
A COUPLE OF HOURS, AND WOKE UP
WITH A 100 PLUS DEGREE FEVER.
THEY PUT ME IN A QUARANTINE
AREA, ENDED UP LANDING AT THE
AIR FORCE BASE, PUT ON THE
PLANE, AND THEY BROUGHT ME COME
ALONG WITH MY WIFE, TO OMAHA.
>> Laura: I’M SORRY, I HAVE TO
ASK THIS.
IS IT TRUE THAT YOUR FAMILY IS
RECEIVING DEATH THREATS?
IS THAT TRUE?
>> YEAH, IT’S REALLY SAD.
WE ARE GETTING DEATH THREATS.
MY WIFE, WHO FINALLY GOT
RELEASED HERE TWO DAYS AGO,
RETURNED -- WE RUN A LOCAL
RADIO STATION IN SANTA CLARITA,
CALIFORNIA.
YES, WE HAVE BEEN GETTING DEATH
THREATS, HATE MAIL, ONE OF OUR
TRAVELING COMPANIONS IS IN A
HOSPITAL IN SALT LAKE CITY.
HE IS GETTING DEATH THREATS.
IT’S LIKE WE HAVE THE FLAG OR WE
ARE LEPERS, IT IS REALLY --
>> Laura: IT’S UNCONSCIONABLE.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY OUTRAGEOUS, AND
YOU ARE COMPLYING WITH WHAT YOU
HAVE TO DO, AND YOU ARE
ISOLATING AND WAITING PATIENTLY,
OBVIOUSLY THAT IS WHAT YOU ARE
SUPPOSED TO DO, AND YOU GET
REPAID FOR THAT BY GETTING DEATH
THREATS.
THANKS.
THAT’S UNBELIEVABLE.
WELL, WE HOPE YOU GET OUT SOON,
CARL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Laura: AND WE JUST PRAY FOR
THE REST OF OUR COUNTRY AND THE
PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD, HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS ARE DOING THE
RIGHT THING, AND IN OUR
GOVERNMENT HAS STRONG RESPONSE.
SO FAR, IT COULD HAVE BEEN A LOT
WORSE, BUT WE WILL SEE WHERE IT